back America Biden it's handled more
papers and it's given Democrats the
vapors
so could documents be the last straw for
America's senile Grandpa
following the White House in Mission
that more classified documents were
found at President Biden's Delaware home
it seems even fellow Thames admit it's
worth a thorough investigation right and
that includes Adam Schiff a guy normally
less interested in the truth in
Madonna's plastic surgeon
yeah so does he think appointing a
special counsel was the right move I do
think it's the right move is it possible
that National Security was jeopardized I
don't think we can exclude the
possibility without no knowing more of
the facts um we have asked for an
assessment in the intelligence community
of the Mar-A-Lago documents I think we
ought to get that same assessment of the
documents holy crap
did our least favorite martian just say
Biden should be treated the same as
Trump
is that even possible hey everybody Joe
Biden gets peed on by Russian hookers
boy would that make Hunter jealous
budship's not the only one Democratic
senators and sycophants are now turning
on Joe
classified documents are to be taken
seriously and they ought to be handled
with a great deal of care nobody's Above
the Law by stumbling and bumbling around
by not getting their timeline right by
by still saying unknown number of
documents found in Biden's correct no no
more unknown Amateur hour is over and
they just mishandled it from day one
because again
I'm only saying it because it's true
only saying it because it's true
excellent reasoning Beavis
no
here's Beavis I keep switching them up
Morning Joe should spring for some name
tags frankly finally CNN's Jim Acosta
accusing Republicans of doing exactly
what the Dems have been doing since the
Big Bang
for many Republicans the argument seems
to be that President Biden is both not
mentally fit to hold office and yet he's
supposed to be this you know in the
minds of some Republicans uh this
criminal mastermind who is holding on to
these documents for some nefarious
reason does that make any sense
used to say the same damn thing about
Trump you jackass
fun fact
fun fact if you just say Kaylee mcinany
to Jim he wets himself
so what's Joe think of all this hey look
look no there's no you can't commit a
crime if you don't know that you're
committing a crime and I I don't even
know what I know there's a box in my
garage but I keep my garage locked
and uh I wouldn't even know how to
there's a button you push a button but
the buttons in the car and the car's in
the garage so how's anyone going to get
in there come on man no it's Martin
Luther King day so could you please let
me get back to calling everyone who
doesn't agree with me a racist thank you
Charlie
I'm sorry when when Adam's Schiff
changes his tune that fast something's
up I smell something yeah what do I
smell Charlie I don't have any evidence
for this but this is my theory since
we're you know talking about President
let's go with it
um I you know so the FBI is already
investigating Hunter Biden I think that
they that at some point I mean imagine
the stuff that we you know think about
all the stuff we've already seen about
about can you imagine if you had like
search warrants and you could like had
investigative Powers imagine the stuff
the FBI is probably digging up about
Hunter Biden now and all of his
connections and I really do believe at
some point and it's happened in the last
couple of weeks since the election they
all got to get and we now know how
deeply invested the Intel Community is
in our uh politics they looked at one
another and said man this is not gonna
we can't we can't get him out yeah we
can't we can't stick up for this guy
yeah we can't do for we can't cover it
for this guy is in the next election
like we did in the last election and I
mean I've never seen rats jumping the
ship uh like this this is crazy cat I
thought that this was going to be
treated like everything else but it
seems like it's not
are the walls closing in
okay I'm gonna try to put this like
gently and kindly what which is
sometimes tough for me I I just don't of
course they would be doing this because
why are they going to go out of their
way to protect Joe Biden because you
know they're worried that oh this is
such a shame that this is happening it's
going to cut short what would be a long
promising political career
he's been in politics just about the
amount of time that United States has
been a country right that's actually I
did math too that is actually a fact so
I mean regardless of whether they decide
to Hitch themselves to this wagon or not
the wagon's not going much further right
so I think it's one of the easiest
things in the world for them to do to
say yeah this is bad because I mean he's
he's really old he's not doesn't seem to
be up to the task of being president nor
has he been the entire time so
I don't know like it's the opposite of
jumping on a bandwagon yeah no I'm I
think you're right you're right this is
terrible because there's no good that
can come from staying by yeah you know I
use this analogy before Joey it's like
when you when all of a sudden the
popular kid in school has done something
really embarrassing and everybody just
lets him you know suffer alone isolation
that never happened I got punched in the
face about girl in the bleachers one
time and I was not popular for a couple
weeks after that yeah matter of fact it
might not have ever been popular to
begin with yes I don't remember block
that part out Hey listen uh Jim Acosta
nobody thinks this dude is a criminal
mastermind no we think he's an idiot we
thank you so much of an idiot that he
takes care of his crackhead son that
leads his laptop everywhere with all the
evidence on it as a matter of fact he's
admitted to most of what he's done I
mean he stood in front of us and told us
that he made a deal to get Ukraine's
equivalent to an investigator out of
office he's told us about the things
he's done we're just all sitting here
twirling our thumbs in amazement that
people like Jim Acosta just don't care
because anything is better than Trump in
their religion and they're they're
coming you know as my mama would say
Jesus is coming back like it's Reckoning
it's time to think about what you've
what you've been worshiping this whole
time
Martha Jesus is coming back what what I
take away from this turn of events that
you guys are all talking about
is this might be really bad if we need
it to be mm-hmm so we're going to keep
this you know all the supporters of the
president and we're going to keep this
on the burner because if we need this
um we're going to employ this this exit
strategy right so they're happy because
now they have an exit strategy and you
can kind of trace the ups and downs of
the Biden uh favorability right because
before he ran or when he was running
they liked everybody but him right David
Axelrod came out and said he was like Mr
Magoo wandering around the stage on the
debates he said he has no idea where he
is and he he shouldn't be doing this
something that would affect then after
the midterms he's just like oh Superman
right and now and you know oh all of a
sudden he's going to run again after
every single one of these people said
there was no way he was going to run
again so now all the way down right so I
think we have a few more of these Cycles
to go before 2024 but as you were saying
we were talking about this in the break
if they don't have somebody else to to
beat their 2024 candidate uh they
probably will find a way to Rally back
around to Joe know if they think he's
the only one that can do it yeah yeah
it's got to pump them full of drugs oh
and it works yeah I mean his performance
the day after the election was one of
the great wonders of modern American
Medicine very strong I'm so amazing I
want what he's having hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else